hay alguna posibilidad ahora en los
siguientes meses de que haya un acuerdo
de paz negociaciones
nosotros tenemos que vencer a Rusia
primero
[Música]
tienen que ir un tribunal Esa es la
única manera de llegar una paz
sostenible recuerde que mencioné ocho
años de acuerdos pacíficos de caminos
diplomáticos ocho años de 2014
todo terminó con un genocidio
Rusia después de bucha después de
maripol
lo que está lo que ocurrió en gersón lo
que ocurrió
cuando las fuerzas armadas liberaron
nuestro territorio vieron tumbas
colectivas
civiles inocentes fueron violados
torturados como podemos olvidar todas
estas muertes nosotros queremos justicia
y la justicia es clave para la paz
sostenible en el continente europeo
porque Rusia seguirá utilizando este
tiempo para obtener más armas de China
y estoy seguro que china está estoy
segura que china está detrás de Rusia
están interesados en vencer a la
civilización occidental por eso es que
Ucrania la victoria de Ucrania es tan
importante para su sociedad también
cuando la conocí usted hicimos un
reportaje en France 24 hace unos meses
con usted aquí en esta iglesia de San
Michelle usted me dijo que estaba un
poco frustrada cuando estaba viajando
alrededor del mundo tratando de hablar
con burócratas a veces no querían
Escuchar Ni entender lo que usted estaba
pidiéndoles todavía está frustrado usted
sí porque ellos no entienden lo que
significa
un ataque masivo de misiles unos drones
kamikazes que matan a civiles inocentes
destruyendo la infraestructura crítica
energética yo he viajado de distintas
capitales en Europa Estados Unidos
Canadá Japón
la gente vive vidas normales nosotros
Les agradecemos por darnos ayuda
humanitaria pero ellos no entienden lo
que significa cuando uno está comiendo
en la cocina y luego llega una bomba
tras otra y bueno te mata
creo que es muy importante recibir el
armamento que necesitamos rápidamente
porque esto retrasa este retraso nos
cuesta vidas Cuál es el valor
estratégico de Ucrania es el pueblo son
los mejores ingenieros los mejores
especialistas en tecnologías de la
información profesores que fueron a la
línea de frente a defender el país todos
nosotros también a defender las
relaciones occidentales del
autoritarismo ruso por supuesto No
entiendo por qué tomó tanto tiempo
convencer a la Unión Europea Alemania De
darnos tanques Por qué después de ocho
años de acuerdos pacíficos cuando hubo
proyectos comerciales con Rusia una
federación como como
porque nosotros estamos enfrentando
genocidio y aún así la situación en el
campo de batalla nos estamos quedando
sin municiones
nosotros no tenemos armas para
defendernos a nosotros por eso es que no
entiendo por qué alguien cree
que el precio de esta guerra bueno
pueden disfrutar su vida Pero qué tal si
mañana les ataca Rusia a un país de la
otan como recientemente ocurrió el
cohete ruso que llegó a Rumanía
el presidente colombiano si algún
presidente latino como Gustavo Petro
como en Colombia dice que es neutral que
no quiere tomar posición que piense
usted
Bueno qué le gustaría decirle usted a
latinoamérica estos líderes que no
quieren tomar posición en esta guerra
lo que Rusia está haciendo es cometer un
genocidio es una guerra colonialista es
un ataque sobre la humanidad Ellos están
destruyendo una nación soberana es algo
que une a todos en este planeta hermoso
porque están destruyendo nos están
destruyendo como seres humanos
estudiando la naturaleza están
destruyendo la energía están destruyendo
absolutamente todo es un ataque en
contra de la vida
creo que cualquiera que tenga hijos o
que sea simplemente un ser humano
no debería
mirar al otro lado o ser neutral porque
la neutralidad significa servir a los
intereses del mal ser parte de un
genocidio malvado
quiero parecer breve está esperando
usted algo particular en kiev en los
próximos días
en Rusia hay movilizaciones actuales los
rusos están preparando para una nueva
ofensiva gran escala por eso es que no
podemos vencer a Rusia porque es una
guerra de desgaste sin munición Sin
armas sin Casas sin jets casa por eso
esperamos ataques renovados aquí desde
el aire por eso es que necesitamos
aviones de ataque porque los ataques
aéreos porque el imperialismo ruso Esto
hace parte de su identidad por eso es
que tenemos empresas que tiene tenemos
que vencerlos en Ucrania e impedir que
ataquen a ninguna nación soberana como
han hecho en moldavia en Georgia en
Georgia
así como han destruido vidas